aunque, principalmente, debíamos pensar en un proceso de diseño
para reutilizar estas piedras talladas al azar.
Algo que no habíamos hecho antes.
Hoy en día, todo sería más fácil
porque iríamos a la cantera
con nuestros teléfonos inteligentes equipados con escáneres 3D,
documentaríamos cada piedra
y lo convertiríamos en un modelo digital.
Todo el proceso muy mecanizado.
Pero hace más de diez años,
teníamos que abrazar la incertidumbre,
ponernos manos a la obra
e ir a la cantera por la experiencia práctica.
También tuvimos que ser los contratistas
porque no encontramos a nadie que quisiera correr el riesgo con nosotros.
Por suerte, el equipo de la cantera nos ayudó a construir algunos prototipos
que resolverían algunos de los detalles técnicos.
Estuvimos de acuerdo con algunos modelos,
nos entusiasmamos,
y una piedra llevó a la otra
hasta que logramos construir
una estructura de 18 metros de largo por 8 metros de alto
que recicló todo el material amorfo de la cantera
sostenido solo por la gravedad
sin mortero ni ataduras.
Una vez que se construyó y testeó,
moverlo a su destino final en el centro de la ciudad
para unirlo con el resto del edificio
fue pan comido,
porque al tener incertidumbres aisladas
y haber manejado el riesgo en el ambiente controlado de la cantera,
pudimos terminar el edificio a tiempo
y dentro del presupuesto,
incluso utilizando medios y métodos no convencionales.
Aún se me pone la piel de pollo
cuando veo este gran macizo del paisaje industrial
en la ciudad,
en un edificio,
utilizado por visitantes y vecinos.
Esta construcción nos dio algunos dolores de cabeza,
y bien podría haber sido una excepción en nuestro trabajo,
sin embargo, nos comenzó a informar un modus operandi
en el que cada proyecto se convierte en la oportunidad
para probar los límites de una disciplina que debería ser reimaginada con urgencia.
Lo que ven aquí son cuatro casas
que hemos diseñado, construido y habitado.
Cuatro manifiestos donde utilizamos una escala menor
para hacernos grandes preguntas.
Y estamos tratando de descubrir la arquitectura que resulta
de la aplicación no convencional de materiales bastante mundanos
y tecnologías,
como las diferentes formas del concreto usado en la primera hilera,
o acero y espuma en la última.
Por ejemplo, estas vigas de cemento precolado.
Probablemente las han visto
en puentes, carreteras, canales hídricos.
Nosotros las encontramos en una visita a una fábrica de cemento precolado.
Y no se deben haber visto particularmente hogareñas o hermosas,
pero decidimos utilizarlas para construir nuestra primera casa.
Fue un momento increíble
porque debíamos ser arquitectos,
una vez más constructores
y, por primera vez, podíamos ser nuestros propios clientes.
Así que aquí estamos tratando de resolver cómo llevar estas vigas gigantes
de alrededor de 20 toneladas cada una
y apilarlas poco a poco en el patio,
el corazón de la casa.
Debido a las dimensiones y la calidad del material,
estas piezas enormes son la estructura que soporta la carga en el terreno.
Pero son más que eso.
Son la piscina,
las paredes que divide el interior del exterior,
las ventanas que enmarcan el paisaje,
las terminaciones,
son el espíritu de la casa.
Una casa que es un laboratorio para nosotros
donde probamos cómo podemos utilizar elementos comunes de modos no tan comunes.
Y vemos que los resultados son fascinantes.
Aprendemos con la práctica
que la prefabricación puede ser más que apilar cajas,
o que las partes pesadas pueden ser ventiladas y transparentes.
Además de diseñar y construir esta casa,
al compartir con nuestras familias y amigos,
obtenemos respuestas muy valiosas
porque es nuestra vida
y trabajo en marcha.
Las lecciones que aprendemos se convierten en otros proyectos
y otros programas
como así también en otras habilidades
que inspiran nuevos trabajos.
Aquí vemos de nuevo productos muy comunes:
tachuelas de acero galvanizado que se pueden cortar y atornillar fácilmente,
espumas aislantes, placas de cemento.
Materiales que puedes encontrar en las paredes de división de una casa
y que nosotros mostramos.
Materiales que utilizamos para crear un sistema de construcción liviana
que pueda utilizar cualquier persona.
Lo hacemos con nuestras propias manos, en nuestro negocio.
Y somos arquitectos, no constructores profesionales.
Pero queremos asegurarnos de que es posible.
Es tan lindo que Antón lo pueda mover con sus manos,
que Javier lo coloque en un contenedor
y que lo podamos transportar
como si transportaras tus pertenencias si te mudaras al extranjero,
que fue lo que hicimos hace cinco años.
Movimos nuestro centro de gravedad
y la casa de vigas de concreto de Madrid a Brookline.
Y encontramos el patito feo de un barrio muy lindo:
un garaje para dos autos y lo único que podíamos pagar.
Pero estaba bien porque queríamos transformarlo en un cisne
e instalamos nuestros ensamblajes recién llegados.
Y nos convertimos una vez más en científicos y conejillos de Indias.
Esta es la casa construida con los materiales más baratos
y más comunes que puedas encontrar en el mercado
que aplica a la modulación omnipresente del cuatro por ocho
que regla la industria de la construcción.
Aún así, con una organización diferente de los espacios
y un ensamblaje diferente de las partes,
se puede transformar una casa construida de forma económica
en un espacio de lujo.
Actualmente, soñamos y trabajamos activamente con desarrolladores,
con constructores,
con comunidades
para hacer de esto una realidad para muchos más hogares
y muchas más familias.
Como ven, el mundo a nuestro alrededor es una fuente infinita de inspiración
si somos lo suficientemente curiosos para ver debajo de la superficie de las cosas.
Ahora les mostraré la otra cara de la moneda:
el paisaje sublime de Montana,
donde hace algunos años junto con Cathy y Peter Halstead
imaginamos el Tippet Rise Art Center en un rancho de 4046.8 hectáreas.
Cuando visitamos el lugar por primera vez,
nos dimos cuenta que todo lo que sabíamos sobre centros de arte
no tenía sentido para ese cliente,
para esa comunidad, para ese paisaje.
El museo con un salón blanco no encajaba aquí.
Entonces decidimos estallar el centro en una constelación de fragmentos,
de espacios desplegados por el vasto territorio
que sumergiría a los visitantes en el desierto de este increíble lugar.
En la oficina, pensamos a través de la creación.
Utilizamos el suelo como soporte y como material.
Aprendemos de sus procesos geológicos de sedimentación, erosión,
fragmentación, cristalización,
explosión,
para descubrir arquitecturas que se originen en el suelo,
que sean extensiones viscerales del paisaje,
como este puente que cruza Murphy Canyon.
O esta fuente.
Como este espacio sobre una colina
o este teatro que nos lleva al espacio de las montañas
y su sonido.
Y para entender esta idea
la construcción no puede ser planeada a la perfección,
necesitamos aceptar el clima drástico y las artesanías del lugar.
Necesitamos controlar esos aspectos críticos
como la propiedades estructurales,
térmicas y acústicas que se encuentran en la forma.
Si no, la improvisación es bienvenida e inducida.
El tiempo de construcción es todavía tiempo de diseño
y tiempo de celebración
donde diferentes manos, corazones y mentes se juntan para el baile final.
El resultado no se puede anticipar.
Es una sorpresa.
Nosotros desenvolvemos la arquitectura como ustedes abren un regalo.
La arquitectura no está descubierta,
hay que descubrirla.
Se extrae de las entrañas de la tierra para construir un refugio,
una de las necesidades más básicas de los seres humanos.
Arquitectura, arte, paisaje,
arqueología, geología, todos son uno.
Y al usar los recursos a nuestro antojo de forma radical,
dando lugar a experimentaciones,
somos capaces de sacar a la luz arquitecturas que encuentran
la belleza latente en cosas imperfectas y en crudo que nos rodean,
que las elevan
y las dejan hablar su propio idioma.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)